c'était une grande première un millier
de personnes réunies pour la marche des
fiertés à saint denis
[Musique]
parmi les manifestants lles alwan
agressé en raison de son orientation
sexuelle à gennevilliers en 2018
il a décidé de lutter contre
l'homophobie en banlieue en banlieue on
est vraiment en arrière dans le temps
au moyen-âge pas loin mais bon c'est
tabou c'est un caddie de révéler son
homosexualité
le militantisme dans les cités a du mal
à se construire
avant les années 2000 l'homosexualité en
banlieue n'était même pas traitée dans
les jt en 2004 année de la pénalisation
de l'homophobie
la question est abordée au 20 heures
avec des lycéens à pantin en région
parisienne à accepter ce genre deux
hommes qui s'embrassent devant nous à la
paix revenait à la violence pourquoi toi
tu autres dont bras c'est ta copine
dehors devant tout le monde
mais l'ue devrait se cacher pour
embrasser qu'est ce que toi en tant que
parent tu assumerait ton gosse ramon
fait je vais parce qu'il est [ __ ]
insultes coups viols
cette violence dans les cités des
victimes la raconte en 2005
de façon assez systématique j'entends
des [ __ ] chaude à saper d'air pour
vivre en paix ismaël a choisi de quitter
sa banlieue j'avais pas honte de moi
mais j'étais vraiment en colère chanter
que c'était pas normal et surtout ce qui
a été plus difficile c'est le sentiment
d'être harcelée pour ce qui reste la
seule solution c'est la dissimulation
mon homosexualité je peux pas dire que
j'ai la vie au grand journal en même
temps elle ne m'empêche pas de vivre
comme je dois villa seul contrat entre
guillemets c'est
une sorte de discrétion qu'il faut avoir
mais tout en étant honnête avec soi-même
l'échappatoire c'est la ville en 2006 un
reportage suit des homosexuels de
banlieue parisienne dans le marais à
paris
si je me sens livre je peux aller boire
un verre 36 lots de rs 100 personnes me
regarde et me montrent du doigt en 2009
brahim naït balk baril mais dans sa
jeunesse sur les terrains de foot violée
dans sa cité à cause de son orientation
sexuelle
il a décidé de parler et de militer
contre atone aux phobies et a créé en
2003 le paris foot gay au fond de moi
c'est une revanche
j'ai fini par aimer ce sport que
j'admire aujourd'hui et là je suis en
train de voir qu'on est en train de s'y
reprendre un vieux deux compères un but
à zéro
ces pavés en 2015 le club a cessé son
activité face à l'indifférence des
institutions difficile de prendre la
parole entre les murs de la banlieue
[Musique]